[Music]  it was really exciting for us to see ed  sheeran in the premiere that was such a  nice surprise one it's cuz Maisie loves  ed Sheeran and David and Dan had it as  like a surprise for her so they just had  they didn't tell her I told her by  accident I was like oh what's that  should be coming on the show but yeah  they kind of did it as a surprise I was  kind of mad cuz I've been talking about  Bieber coming on the show for a while  now but it's fine  I'm over it I've got a little bit of  backlash from the fans on Twitter for  appearing on Game of Thrones what do you  have to say about that you did I thought  you killed it ed Sheeran is a hero no  one no one Slade ed Sheeran that's rude